[Applause]
the Israeli Army is pushing deeper into
Gaza the number of Dead Rising by the
hour the Israelis insist the aim of the
war is the destruction of Hamas but now
Benjamin Netanyahu says his forces will
oversee Security in the strip for an
indefinite period raising the clear
possibility of a level of military
occupation I think Israel will
for an indefinite period will have the
overall uh security responsibility
because we've seen what happens when we
don't have it when we don't have that
security responsibility what we have is
the eruption of Hamas Terror on a scale
that we couldn't
imagine Israel withdrew from its illegal
settlements and Military positions in
Gaza in 2005 finally handing back
territory it seized in
1967 moving troops in for an extended
period or indefinite stay would be the
first Israeli presence of its kind in 18
years defense minister yov Galant has
told an Israeli Parliament committee
that the country faces a long engagement
in Gaza one that might not end with the
current
fighting at the end of this campaign
there will be no Hamas as a ruling
military organization in Gaza there will
be no security threat from the Gaza
Strip on Israel and Israel will have
complete freedom of action to act in any
situation when there's any threat in the
Gaza Strip it's unlike anything else
we've done but one expert says the idea
of any level of reoccupation is
premature it is impossible to to say now
that whatever happens Israel will remain
the security wise and be able to do
whatever it wants we still don't know
what exactly will be the kind of regime
in Gaza once Hamas hopefully is not
leading this area there has been a lot
of talk in Israel and internationally
about what happens when the war War is
Over the thing to remember is that it's
still ongoing the US wants to see a
two-state solution the standard for
decades but that would be much harder to
achieve if Israeli forces are still
occupying part of the Gaza Strip Allan
fiser Al jaaz in occupied East
Jerusalem well let's discuss all this
now with our senior political analyst
Maran Bashar who joins us here on the
set so it was see Marwan that in Israel
the conversation about the day after has
already began even as the war rages on
what do you make of this Netanyahu plan
of Israel indefinitely maintaining
Security in
Gaza well let's just start by saying it
certainly goes uh contrary to American
wishes what Biden asked for absolutely
Biden said much early on that this would
be a big mistake in the words of the
American president because he realizes
all too well that isra is tried that uh
for some what 30 years and clearly
that's not that's not a workable
plan uh but I think Israel doesn't have
much of an endgame and I think the prime
minister is probably making things as he
goes along October 7 was a shock for the
Israelis and they needed to do something
about it and now that they are in the
midst of War what else can you do when
you want to occupy a territory than
occupy uh the territory now indefinitely
and control of course course that could
mean a number of things meaning it could
mean we we maintain an over oral control
but we bring a puppet regime a puppet
someone to sort of handle the
administration of the Gaza street right
so what about this us position in the US
role now as you said Biden has said it
would be a mistake for Israel to
reoccupy Gaza how do you see the US role
evolving we've got Lincoln in Japan for
the G7 meeting does America today have
any leverage on this Israeli government
well tell you just briefly we've been
what now a month into the
War uh you could say just until the
bombing of the hospital on the
17th uh and a bit few days after that by
the time Biden left back to the United
States from a visit to Israel he
maintained the argument that the war was
solid the war was necessary Israel
wasn't was going to get Justice it's
Justified and America is 100% behind
Israel on the War I think in the second
half of the month the American discourse
began to change it felt like it was
losing the war argument and it started
embracing the day after argument because
clearly much of the Arab world much of
the International Community was not
buying into the American justification
of Israel's war crimes in Gaza so they
start talking about the peace the day
after or the peace process the day after
but as
uh as we've heard just now in the report
and as it's be clear to everyone once
the Israelis going to become Victorious
presumably big presumably big if out of
Gaza the last thing they going to do is
to hand Gaza or the occupied West Bank
to anyone let alone the Palestinian
Authority in order to establish a
state I I I think for the American
administration at this point in time the
end game is not clear just as it is not
clear for Israel I think it's quite a
mess and to be clear to be clear
Israel's bombardment the last 72 hours
is a sign of desperation on the part of
the Israelis clearly they're not able to
make an advance and their big Claim
about Hamas using civilians as as human
shield as human shield is now exactly
the opposite meaning Israel is pounding
the
civilians in the Gaza Strip in in order
to [__] the Gaza Strip in order to
get to the fighters so in fact Israel is
punishing the people of Gaza the 2.2
million people in Gaza for what Hamas
did in October 7 because they cannot get
to Hamas because Hamas presumably
somewhere underground and it's not able
to get to them right and clearly the
resistance against the encroaching
Israeli forces is so vicious and severe
that the Israelis are getting frustrated
and they're taking it out on the people
Revenge right in the last few minutes
Netanyahu has said that there will be no
ceasefire re reiterating that there'll
be no ceasefire in Gaza without the
release of Israeli captives and he's
also warned Hezbollah not to join the
war or it'll be making a big mistake in
his Wars but the captives when you look
at the way Israel has been bombing the
Gaza Strip you wonder if they even care
about these captives anymore well you
know there is an Unwritten rule uh uh in
the Israeli establishment and in fact
this Unwritten rule was devised in
2017 it's called the Hannibal Doctrine
and the Hannibal Doctrine for the
Israeli military establishment means
after sort of a long history of uh of
getting in trouble with this idea of
captives and hostages so on so forth is
that if needs be Israel will
sacrifice captives and
hostages in the name of National
Security and I I can see that from from
the Israeli pronouncements and from the
uh from netanyahu's being so adamant in
continuing the war and not accepting any
pause the pounding of Gaza means that
they've already in the middle of the
Hannibal doctrine that they have given
up on the idea of the captives and the
hostages and that they're going to
continue to
pound uh the Gaza Strip regardless of
what happens to them and I think that's
why Bill Burns is in the area mhm
because there are also hostages captives
that are not Israeli yeah that they're
Americans and they are worried about
them and by the way just quickly fully
on the other part of what you mentioned
I think it's clear that to me as I've as
I've written today on our
website if if President Biden is not
able to lean on the Israeli government
to accept a 2hour humanitarian
pause how then how in hell mhm Will
President Biden promise a two-state
solution if he can deliver a 2hour
humanitarian pause how will he deliver a
two-state solution to the Palestinians
that he's been boasting about now for
two weeks right speaking of that I know
we we can't be talking about the
postconflict scenario just yet because
of what's still going on but to achieve
real political
gains and to ensure that this doesn't
happen again what do Palestinians need
to do not just those in Gaza but in the
West Bank as well what do they need to
demand
today end of end to the occupation is of
course the only way forward there is no
security for the Palestinians and
there's no security to the Israelis as
long as the occupation exists and
there's no military Solutions and I
would argue moving forward I mean my
personal opinion if I'm allowed one is
that there is no military solution for
either party
but I think the Palestinians need to do
two things first of all they need to
unite behind a popular resistance to the
occupation but they need to unite and if
the settlers come and attack villagers
they need to stand up for each other in
the West Bank as much as they're trying
to stand up for each other in the West
Bank and Gaza and in East Jerusalem and
the second thing is that they need to
understand that America is not their
savior America is Israel's Ally advocate
and unconditional supporter they need
the International Community at large and
that includes Europe and the rest of the
world unless the International Community
comes together as they did on the
questions of aparted South
Africa as they did on the questions of
the French occupation of
Algeria unless the International
Community comes comes along with or in
candem with popular resistance by the
Palestinians of with the support of the
Arab world then they probably could
reach somewhere but to leave it to the
Israelis the goodwi of the Israelis and
the Good Will of the American
administrations I think that's not just
fantasy that's farsal Maran always good
to get your Insight thank you very much
and you can read maran's latest article
on our website the farce of post Gaza PX
Americana in the Middle East that's at
Al ja.com thank you very much